five Democratic lawmakers are demanding
the Justice Department investigate the
killing of a black man Marquis
McLaughlin by a white gunman this month
in an argument over a parking space in
Florida the shooter claimed self-defense
under the state's Stand Your Ground law
it's the latest example of the
controversial measure that first gained
national attention in 2012 when George
Zimmerman shot and killed teenager
Trayvon Martin who was unarmed and
walking home in his Florida neighborhood
Zimmerman was acquitted of murder the
shooting created a national outcry it
led to the black lives matter movement
and the backlash against it
a new documentary series rest in power
the Trayvon Martin story tracks the long
lasting consequences of that night after
those 91 tapes are released people were
outraged and they wanted to know more
suddenly everybody knew who Trayvon
Martin was Trayvon Trayvon Trayvon
Martin it was like an explosion that
thousands of Americans are demanding
justice and the people wouldn't stop
tens of thousands of people be rallying
today it took my son he has shot down to
make me stand up
[Music]
we reached out to George Zimmerman for
comment on the story but did not hear
back Trayvon Martin's father Tracy
Martin is here along with filmmakers
Jenna first and Julia Willoughby Neeson
good morning to all of you thank you so
much for being here
good morning us Tracy thank you so much
for joining us why was it's been it's
been now how many years since your son
was ill six years six years there's yes
why was it so important to be involved
in this project I think the importance
of this was to show the country that we
need social change there are a lot of
social injustice occurring in our
communities and and the problem needs to
be rectified it's hard to believe it's
been six years that was that that was
our number one story for so many months
and I feel like we're still living the
after-effects of that story how did you
get involved in this project
jay-z reached out to Jenna and I we had
just finished working on a project with
him about kalief Browder who is a young
man held in Rikers Island for three
years without a trial and we went from
there this this begins with with
Trayvon's death but it goes much bigger
than that what were you what were you
what was your what were you aiming for
here with this documentary I think the
central thesis of our documentary is
that Trayvon Martin's story ignited
change in America but also led to a
backlash that we're currently
experiencing in our politics and we
wanted to use the case to explore that
backlash and understand how it's
affecting our daily life now I think you
look at all the headlines and so much
has changed but so much is the same look
at what just happened to ving rhames
right look at look at Marquis McLaughlin
that's a stand-your-ground case this is
still a major issue in America and I
think we have to face it and have honest
conversations about it and we're
beginning to understand how uneven the
landscape is when it comes to unarmed
victims of color right Washington Post
reports that in the past decade more
than two-thirds 70% of murder victims
whose killers were never arrested
two-thirds were black right what
that tell you mr. Martin that the scales
of justice are unbalanced and we
actually are in the place where we made
a little progress with our previous
administration and so I think it's going
to take the power of the people getting
out voting to to shift this shifted the
dynamics of how African American men and
women are viewed in this country Jenner
George Zimmerman recently was charged
with stalking the private investigator
that you hired right and that's part of
this story tell us about that well I
think you know there's an ongoing
investigation so I can't say too much
but what I can say is that it was
alarming how unhinged this person is and
the fact that he is permitted to carry
several firearms rifles shotguns assault
rifles and walk around with a
bulletproof vest after it's been proven
that he killed an unarmed 17 year old
young man and also has abused several
women who went to the police reporting
those crimes so what we found was
extremely alarming and I don't think it
I think it's you know not surprising
that he turned on Dennis Warren and in
our producer Mike espero and started
stalking them we Ryder we did reach out
to George Zimmerman for comment but it
didn't receive an answer Tracy it cannot
have been easy for you to relive all
this
what made you really want to go through
with this project well we feel as though
as parents we felt as though the story
was was watered down that was being told
about Trayvon who he truly was and the
perception that he was a thug this was a
17 year old unarmed child on this way
from the store going home had nothing to
do with him being a thug and it had
everything to do with racial profiling
and so we felt they were as parents that
we needed to tell the story of who
Trayvon truly was Julia this documentary
also draws a direct line between
Trayvon's killing and the rise of white
nationalism and race based violence in
America plot some of that out for us
will tree vote Martin's
gave birth to black lives matter the
verdict was when the hashtag was created
so we chronicled the birth of black
lives matter all the way to the white
lash the opposite side reaction to that
so we go from Trayvon to Trump and we
really see the connective tissue to the
last six years and how our political
landscape is really just thrown into a
mass chaos today you talk about the
political landscape you mentioned voting
you have an election coming up in
November for people who are outraged by
this and violence that shows no sign of
abating by the way what should they do
what should they think about November I
think in November we think about putting
people in place that are willing to
listen and take action on the social
justice in justices that are current
across this country we can't sit back
and let another term go by without going
out putting people in place that will
make a change mm-hmm and do some of that
change you want to see legislative
change stand your ground is at the heart
of truth Martin Marquess mcLaughlin
that's also a stand-your-ground case I
mean tell us more about that well I
think that you know the hope with a
series like this is that it can be a
teaching tool that people can watch it
and if they're affected by it if what
they see they feel is wrong they can use
their civic duty of voting to change the
story and stand your ground it's very
unfortunate that the law was passed to
begin with but it's in over 20 states
across this country look at what's just
happened to mark piece McLaughlin look
at what happened to Trayvon Martin if
you believe that was wrong if you
believe that people should not have the
right to kill because they say they are
afraid which is a very subjective term
and has a lot of racial undertones then
you should hold your politicians
responsible in this November you should
vote those out of office who disagree
Wow Trayvon Martin's life may be over
but his story goes on Tracy Martin
Jenner first and Julia Willoughby Nason
thank you guys so much and and the
documentary premieres tonight on
paramount and
the network BT congratulations thank you
thank you